we have the number forty three thousand
two hundred and forty nine and what i
want you to think about is what these
two fours actually represent and how
much more value is represented by this
first four this four on the left than
this four on the right and i encourage
you to pause this video and think about
that
so let's just think about what each of
these digits represent
so the 9 is in the ones place so it
literally represents 9 ones
the fir this 4 on the right i should say
is in the tens place
so it literally represents four tens or
four times ten or forty
this two is in the hundreds place
so it literally represents two hundreds
or two hundred
this 3 is in the thousands place so it
represents three thousands
and then the four on the left is in the
ten thousands place
ten thousands place so it literally
represents four
times ten thousand or four ten thousands
or
forty
forty thousand
so let's actually compare the value that
we're getting here versus here so what's
the difference in forty thousand and
forty
well 40 000 has four zeros while 40 only
has one so if you wanted to go from 40
to 40 000 you would have to add three
more zeros and we already know how to do
that you could add three more zeros by
multiplying multiplying by a thousand so
forty thousand is equal to one thousand
times forty or we could say the four on
the left here this blue circled four
represents four represent the the blue
circled four represents one thousand
times the value as the yellow circled
four now another way of thinking about
it
is every time you move place values to
the left as you see here this is tens
hundreds thousands ten thousands you're
increasing what those place values
represent by a factor of 10
so you're going if you're going from
this 4 to this 4
times 10 times 10
times 10. you multiply by 10
the place value and you see that with
the place values right over here the
place values increase by a factor of 10
each time so if you're going from this
place to this place and you have the
exact same digit there multiplying by 10
three times is the same thing as
multiplying by a thousand so whatever
this represents multiply it by a
thousand and you're going to get what
this represents